qu'est ce qui à kelly non on peut le
dire quoi si vous avez très pense que
c'est une personne qui a été retrouvée
de twitter qui pensent que c'est la
fille de bernard montiel
j'écoute et je ne peux pas
je découvre alors je vais moi j'ai
découvert séquence
dans les tombeaux du service adéquat je
me sens affreusement concernés tu fais
bien
non c'est la regarde je vois qu elle me
regarde une façon très particulière et
très gentil d'ailleurs et je me sens
concerné chez navré je me sens très fort
on n'en fait rien nous semble très fort
oui c'est que c'est un médium moi aussi
non c'est vrai passé mais que ce centre
vous alors on va en discuter non mais je
sens très fort c'est babu sortie de
réformes annoncées juste valeur vénale
bc je suis
sérieux je crois
19h03 c'est aussi le prix baisser la
masse mais c'est tout ce que vous pouvez
baisser
j'espérais respire versées ou saccharine
à temps et coûte l'équipe sans mon
accord je répète et je me fait très
plaisir tout ça parce que vous êtes
extrêmement gentil extrêmement
sympathique vous a contacté parce que
dimanche sur twitter vous avez
interpellé bernard montiel en dix ans
bernard je te souhaite un bon dimanche
faut mettre le tweet un merci se
souhaite un bon dimanche je pense à toi
papa chéri d'efforts pokémon soit quoi
berne a répondu à arrêter vos délires je
ne suis pas votre père ou je vous bob
définitivement closer public voici
apparemment ont repris cette affaire ah
bon oui oui tout le monde a repris et
voilà voilà voilà voilà
je prenais le karine karine
fait mais je pensais que c'était une
blague juste avant oui je veux dire m
oui j'ai eu karine donc plusieurs fois
en privé à d'accord en lui demandant d'
arrêter cela hec ripaille voilà karine
maintenant alors c'est vous alors vous
êtes très jolie en plus voulu faire un
bisou j'aurais été très fier mais on est
d'abord un biseau après on raconte
l'histoire c'est pas moi je vais faire
des bisous mais c'est bon alors allez
raconter une histoire
déjà merci beaucoup chouette oui ça me
permet enfin de
devoir vous faites donc le but c'était
ça c'était de ce soir et
et l'histoire
baliste l'histoire c'est ma maman en
fait c'est et c'est toi et à ta maman
c'est moi je ne peux pas me moquer de sa
ca bien sûr sérieux karine je vous en
prie à l'isi mais c'est très touchant
d'autres trucs là je sais pas si c'est à
dire ici je sais que c'était important
pour toi
donc non ce que je vais pas dire que tu
étais ma maman c'est que ça regarde
maman et toi et et qu'aujourd'hui elle
est pas l épicier le sait pas
non mais c'est qui votre moment c'est
mimi
en 92 ans apparemment vidéo gaga voilà
l'accord promu assistant de production
ah oui ah non non non ça non
bravo bernard
c'est hyper sérieux
merci sous plus on n'a pas besoin de
quelqu'un qui nous est karine non mais
c'est pas une blague
parce que non parce que ici c'est
répondront
donc on pensait on était persuadé que
c'était une blague sur twitter je vous
dis la vérité ces personnes et que c'est
une blague sur twitter que c'était un
truc voilà c'est énorme
c'est vrai et que là on se dit parce
qu'en fait gimont et péter personnes et
que c'est une vanne sur twitter et
bernard et que vous disiez ma chérie
c'est un running à la wii on s'est dit
ça nous faisait mari non je rêvais
gentiment mais je sais mais je savais
pas que c'était au début je répondais
j'entends que ces titres étaient une
vraie histoire mais non c'est pas une
vraie histoire attend des heures me me
dit moi qui est mimi précisément alors
mais c'est donc ma maman oui kim kim kim
a eu en 92 oui et donc du coup là est
assistant tout ça sur vidéo gag oui
c'est exact ça mais apparemment c'était
vraiment bref et là c'est dernièrement
donc j'ai eu j'ai un petit garçon et
est donc j'ai besoin d'avoir plus
d'infos et donc voilà elle m'a informé
bon sheila est ce que je peux dire tout
simplement que ce n'est pas possible
d'accord non mais oui on va pas rentrer
là dedans on va pas rentrer dedans par
le real il faut par le real quand je
vous parlerai karine ans je vous fais un
petit bisou
c'est pas possible écoutez
je vous en parlerai mais je suis désolé
bayrou vous en parlerez tous les deux en
même en parlerait pas ce que ces musées
sérieuses et je sens que ça vous affecte
moi moi ça me gêne par rapport à vous
parce que c'est faux et je suis désolé
pour vous vraiment encore gérer
l'impression de tomber dans l'histoire
de mon temps là tu avais joué mais moi
j'étais persuadé que c'est même moi je
m'en fous non monsieur cas merci mais
c'est vrai que ce sera moi donc vous
discutiez avec de rien en tout cas
d'être charmant et puis tu es grand père
alors
[Applaudissements]
allez-y calaisis et s'appelle bernard du
coup le petit oui ma fille s'appelle
bianca
[Rires]
et c'est prêt et voilà j'ai écrit un
poème motion ça vous intéresse je sais
pas c'était pas le bassiste six rapports
de quoi le poème
d aller jusqu à cinq longueurs
touchons
non mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec
mini ah oui c'est déjà je me rappelais
quitté nîmes i ce serait bien avant mais
on ne peut pas être incorrectes je suis
désolé des mini j'en connais plein c'est
incroyable allez-y alors bestiaux
alex est mon cher papa papa ma présence
aujourd'hui n'est pas à
respecter
sinon
respecter la souffrance
vas-y karimova d'événements non mais non
désiré ecaré maintenant karine en
malaisie
pour avancer après socialiser les
gt1 par interpeller sur twitter le coeur
rempli d'espoir tu as fait le choix de
m'ignorer alors qu en te voyant j'ai
l'impression d'être devant un miroir
papa depuis tout petit je suis fier de
dire que tu es mon héros
est jetée suivi partout de vidéo gag à
la chaîne des animaux
attention le viseur des voix pas dire
assez
c'est émouvant
mais je suis fatigué de voir mon papa à
travers un écran tv sous le pouce plus
voir
ça de sarrebourg
mais je suis là pour enfin se rencontrer
et et que comme un père et une fille tu
es tu viens m'embrasser
je viens vous embrasser comme je
je je viens vous avancez avec plaisir
mais pas comme un papa parce que ce tube
à votre père mais je veux bien vous en
pensez avec plaisir après compagne
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais pourquoi
pourquoi ils font pas un test mais ils
ont déjà fait un test faire chier gabès
atteste qu'au vide non
évidemment non mais non bien sûr en tout
cas en tout cas elle est super mais
peut-être pas descendre franchement
alors c'était du c'est une commune c'est
qu'on veut
m
si bon dimanche c'est une comédienne
exceptionnelle fait peur
je me tenir il ya eu un doute sur la
période il a plu ce voyage est cuit
pour aller tester les hôtels accor et
oui du coup il existe toujours la dame
de twitter alors la vie de tout
électrique la dame twitter robert ménard
mais laisser la lada nous à la retrouver
et merci c'est ainsi qu'en
[Applaudissements]
il en fait trop mal et